you get the first pick in the comeback
player of the year uh candidates draft
wow there's a lot to pick from here um
damn i don't even know which one i'm
gonna go with big ben first
i mean yeah big ben at his a big ben big
ben
how can you not do the song i was just
about to and you're right how did i drop
the ball there but yes i am going with
him i mean
it's like clockwork baby big ben
big ben big ben big ben i mean
at his age 7-0 football team
playing good football making big throws
in every game
and the big thing is not messing up any
games either to where it's put them in a
tough spot to where they have to come
back or anything like that
but i guess the severity of that injury
you know throwing elbow
at his age and then to come back and
still look the way he does and
everything and leading that football
team i'm gonna make him one
peter king said a few weeks back that if
alex smith takes even one snap this year
he gets his vote for comeback player of
the year alex smith did play
i argued a couple of weeks ago he should
be the starter maybe we'll see him at
some point but we've seen enough
given the devastating nature of that
injury that almost claimed his life
and if not his life his leg alex smith
would be my first pick
yeah okay that's a good one i i hear you
there i mean he certainly was on my list
i don't know how i can't go to aldon
smith i mean the guy was out of football
for five freaking years
i mean that's just it's insane to me
and that he is sitting here right now at
13th and football and sacks with five
i mean it's just it's amazing again uh
it just there's not many people in the
history of the sport
who could take five years off come back
be a starter
and then not just be like oh hey yeah he
starts for us but we're looking to
replace him
like oh no he starts and he's one of our
better players on the defensive side of
the ball
that is uh mind-boggling to me i don't
know maybe
just as much mind-boggling as the alex
smith thing really it's very close it's
crazy how good he's doing
he's tailed off a little bit the last
four weeks but he he should have been
the defensive player of the month in the
nfc for september i don't know whether
there's some bias against him in the
league office and the people who make
those selections there was a week he
should have been defensive player of the
week he should have been defensive
player of the month
and and maybe he'll get votes for
comeback player of the year next one for
me
even though i still don't like that
stupid drizzles like maple syrup thing
from last week
i got to go with gronk yeah it took him
a while to get up to speed he was
running in maple syrup the first few
weeks of the season
but now he's doing gronk things and
after taking a full year off of football
and unretiring i'd have to give gronk
serious consideration yeah
i i that was the one i struggled with
between him and alden smith and
you know especially the way gronks
looked
the last three weeks you just go uh-oh
he looks like the old gronk to me i mean
it's
it's very close it's impressive it's
certainly he's gotten back into
i'm a mismatch and you better think
about who you want covering me
type territory and that's pretty damn
impressive man there's a lot of good
ones i mean
really i mean i don't even know where to
go here
you know i got bradley chubb here um
i even put todd gurley in i know it's
not like
officially one of those guys but he's
having a secretly great
year after we all thought he was done i
mean even alvin kamara
and i put miles garrett in the list here
but i'm going to give love
to somebody who has not gotten love and
i want to do it stefan to it
okay for the pittsburgh steelers he
the steelers have three pass rushers
that are in the top seven in football
and sacks
stefan tuitt is at number seven with six
sacks he's a guy that is a true beast
who's dealt with injuries a lot over the
last few years
and is a phenomenal football player so i
just want to give him some love because
when i watch the steelers every week i
go whoa
is he the best defensive player on the
team i mean it's that kind of good so
good for him bounce it back this year he
had two sacks three tackles for loss and
three quarterback hits on sunday against
the ravens there was one play where
he looked like aaron donald the way that
he just completely
shut like picked up and through a guy
who was blocking him
enroute to sacking lamar jackson last
one for me teddy bridgewater even though
he was 5-0 last year okay he wasn't a
starter
he's back after that long arduous
journey from the
fluke torn acl with other damage that
supposedly nauseated teammates
and he looks good and his team is for a
rebuilding team
they're not bad they've been competitive
and teddy has looked very very good so
that's it and there are plenty of others
out there that could
get consideration i have a feeling it's
going to be alex smith or big ben though
especially if the steelers keep doing
what they're doing i think tom brady
could maybe get consideration because
last year he wasn't very good right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports